the first trailer for The Boy spin-off
gen V has dropped and is filled with all
of the violence sex and not so
superheroes that we've come to expect
from the franchise along with a few
familiar faces
ever since the beginning of the boys
Ashley Barrett has been a key character
in the series constantly doing damage
control and trying to keep things apart
from getting totally derailed Ashley
often appears to be the most stressed
out character on the boys based on the
New Gen V trailer it looks like this
trend will continue
she's vibrating it faster that stick up
her ass is gonna explode while Ashley is
only shown briefly in the trailer for
Gen V she has her typical oh crap
expression of shock and disbelief that
means there's going to be at least one
mess that she has to clean up an example
of the kinds of disasters you'll have to
deal with might be hinted at by a few
characters who are seen wearing ribbons
on their chest in the trailer these
ribbons could allude to a possible
tragedy on the compass given her habits
of literally pulling out her hair during
the latest public relations catastrophe
we're wondering if Ashley will have any
left at the end of the first season of
gen V add to that the potential for the
seven contributing to the chaos of the
show and it's a good thing that she's
already invested in a high quality wig
though a train was originally set up as
one of the most hateable characters in
The Voice the corrupted former Hero has
become something of an anti-hero over
the course of the series while he
remains morally dubious season 3 saw a
train at least trying to make a
difference it even had him taking
vigilante justice into his own hands and
brutally killing the racist super blue
hawk since the characters seems to be
growing something of a conscience his
inclusion in gen V could point to a
Redemption Arc for him though the shots
of him in the trailer preparing for a
racist from season one of the boys there
is a very brief shot of him sporting a
seven ball cap at some kind of school
event this suggests that he will play at
least some part of the story for the
first season of course it remains to be
seen how much screen time returning
characters like a train actually have in
gen V but the fact that there will be
characters from the main series helps to
suggest that the spin-off series will
make a meaningful contribution to the
overall lore of the universe
University is advertised as a safe space
to allows superheroes to become the best
versions of themselves however that
claim couldn't be further from the truth
as the trailer proves that something
violence is going down behind closed
doors at the score one scene from the
teaser shows a student being dragged
through underground corridors by armed
guards another depicts a member of a
security team being killed so violently
you can see someone's hand coming out of
his mouth from The Assault whatever's
happening at this secret facility
clearly isn't legal and the narration
suggests that the people who run the
university are overseeing the Twisted
operation
everything is
the tyrants Who Run The Scholar as
corrupt as they come gadolkin University
is owned by vart International the
corporation that built the sage Grove
Center The Boys season 2 reveals that
the so-called mental health facility is
actually a prison where humans are
experimented on so the underground
horror chamber that's shown in the Gen V
trailer may be used for similar purposes
[Music]
soups are no strangers to partying
heartily and the trailer for Gen V hints
that there are going to be wild times or
plenty and this college-based spin-off
we briefly see a group of characters
drunkenly celebrating during a house
party and one character shape-shifting
during a night out on the town it looks
like college life for the young
superhumans will be no different than
how it is for an average teenager and we
got some big hints that is not easy
dating as a soup throughout the trailer
it's also worth noting that the rages in
this trailer definitely hearken back to
outlandish House Parties who's seen on
the boys in season one butcher takes
Huey to a party to track down a train
and that's when Huey gets his first
taste under supe's hedonistic lifestyle
and who can forget her orgasm in any
event it feels like gen V is definitely
trying to connect the dust between
Huey's experience and the boys and what
Marie Moreau goes through as a freshman
one of the weirdest and funniest
additions to season three of the boys
was the fact that Ultra brutal hero
black noir saw Rising colorfully
animated cartoon characters existing
alongside him in the real world it looks
like gen v may be continuing this trend
only with a bit of a different take late
in the trailer we see two puppets and a
neon drenched black lit hallway that's
one of the two brutally guilty other
causing glitter to spurt from its body
rather than blood waters could allude to
another character who sees reality
differently from everyone else this
moment in the Gen V trailer could also
be caused by a drug trip after all the
show is set in college where students
are known to experiment with illicit
substances and of course characters in
the universe of the boys have not
exactly shown a ton of restraint when it
comes to substance abuse
there was always going to be some
crossover between the boys and gen V
with various Subs making at least Cameo
appearances and the new trailer provides
a look at another important voice
character entering the mix congresswoman
Victoria Newman it's a brief Glimpse but
it shows Victoria on stage with a sign
behind her that partially reads the
dolkin town hall while it's unlikely to
play a major role in gen V the image
does suggest how the show will set up
future storylines for her going into the
boys season 4. she's always had powerful
political aspirations leading the charge
against Subs while having head exploding
Powers herself plus season 3 featured
the death of Lamar Bishop setting up
Victoria to become Robert singer's
running mate her appearance in gen V
could simply set up this Arc further and
if she gains more political power that
only makes her more of a threat
as the next vice president I will work
hard to provide a safe and secure future
for all citizens on both sides of the
political line
there has cast a long Shadow over the
universe of the boys from the very
beginning so it makes sense that he will
remain a part of the World building in
gen V even if he doesn't show up in
person in the series for starters the
trailer features a shot of Marie Moreau
looking up at a homelander statue on
Compass we also see a shot later on that
shows a student powering up her laser
ice something the leader of the seven is
well known for doing throughout the boys
however the students has orange eye
lasers rather than red ones so we can
safely assume that the character is not
homelander CERN Ryan he's probably still
a bit young for college anyway
considering that butcher had orange
lasers by using compound V in season 3
it's very likely this character got his
powers the same way will this suit be a
hero or villain we don't know for sure
but given the source material even if he
does try to fight for good it won't be
without bending or breaking just about
every rule along the way
given that the show is about young
super-powered adults heading to college
there is no question that the show is
intended to draw parallels to Marvel's
X-Men franchise the difference here of
course is that while students at Charles
Xavier score would go on to be
superheroes no one in the universe or
the boys is a hero additionally students
at the school for gifted mutants
generally came by their powers naturally
while students at gedolkin were created
with compound V like everything in the
boys the new spin-off will certainly be
a social satire this time taking apart
college life in America you could be the
first top ranked freshman in history I
think you meant to say first black woman
in the seven
beyond that it will be a commentary on
the insanity of training young minds to
be crime Fighters parodying the
idealistic vision of young Vigilantes as
portrayed in the X-Men it doesn't hurt
either that the show comes out right
before Marvel Studios is set to fold in
the X-Men franchise into its larger and
immensely successful MCU with any luck
gen V will be in the minds of fans
everywhere as the X-Men gets a fresh
reboot from Kevin feige and his team of
creatives and Marvel Studios
after seeing congresswoman Newman and
Ashley in the Gen V trailer it's fair to
wonder exactly when the spinoff series
takes place within the larger universe
of the boys it appears that Newman is
complaining for something in every Flash
and while the shots at the beginning of
the trailer of a train Queen Maeve and
homelander come from previous episodes
of the boys it anchors that gen v as
being contemporary with the original
show and finally seeing a train in the
seven ball cap shows that the soup is up
and about after his heart surgery and
ready to get some more face time with
his adoring fans in 2022 showrunner Eric
Kripke spoke with deadline about the
series blossoming and Savage Universe
when asked about how interconnected the
boy's diabolical engine v will be he
said there's definitely crossover and
we're doing our best to design a
universe that sees some of the issues
and storylines in season 3 hand off to
the first season in Varsity he went on
to reveal a few details about the show
and how it affects the universe of the
boys he said like there's a presidential
campaign happening in the background of
that season and there are dozen things
that are happening at that school that
are both in reaction to season three of
the boys but also some new storylines
that are happening in that season of the
spin-off that we have to pick up and
take into season 4 of the show he
further tease the show's connectivity to
the boys telling collider people will be
surprised as they come into the show and
the show evolves the implications that
gen V has on The Voice the two shows
have some really interesting connections
[Music]